hello YouTube community
I'm Greg Alva today I want to be
watching the trailer for Guy Ritchie's
can't believe he's doing this King
Arthur legend of the sword official
trailer I have my skepticism I'm not
going to lie because I don't know it's a
slave King Arthur my favorite King
Arthur movies Excalibur the the classic
film Excalibur way too young when I
watch that movie
there's like sex and violence and it
really made an impression on my
sensitive brain and then you know they
got Anton food well the directors cuts
pretty good a guy Richie I'm a little
skeptical a little skeptical but hey a
lot of people is this this is requested
I keep forgetting to mention that he
said when I said help is requested from
this guy this Asian name no idea what it
says I don't want to come across racist
and guess what if I had to Bruce chin
oh thank god there was a trailer for a
trailer with me sure Troy
[Music]
that's a lot
could you see everything you needed to
see why is the wolf job why did the
phone work to achieve it no that can't
be a leader you will not grow into one
look look look about don't worry you'll
soon understand what all the first
[Music]
English
whoa just a nice buff
you want me to process this is your
[ __ ]
I think of one over I saw the first
trailer in the theaters as I didn't film
a reaction to it that was a really cool
[ __ ] trailer man the song I forgot
the name of that Zeppelin song but it's
a really cool song we're surprising well
with the trailer I'm really glad they
didn't use a cover and they actually
just use the og song you know Guy
Ritchie was a music video director prior
to becoming a film director his movies
really reflect the music video style
kind of directing him and all the way
back like Lock Stock and Two Smoking
Barrels I've wanted him to go back to
those like British gangster drama comedy
the kinks you know what I mean and I was
a little worried about this because you
know he did Sherlock Holmes Sherlock
Holmes was a very entertaining film
there really does feel like you know
like the modernized version I know it
takes place back then but it still feels
like you know a guy Richie modernized
Sherlock Holmes version this is for the
modern-day audience and well I'm sure
King Arthur might feel that way it
really looks like from the visual
aesthetic that Guy Ritchie is really
embracing the fantasy flair the
historical flair it doesn't seem like
he's just doing crazy Guy Ritchie cool
stuff the whole time like wow there's a
lot of that in there like those action
sequences look great the visual effects
look really cool I love the use of
Excalibur the all the cool mystical
elements of Excalibur look pretty
[ __ ] sweet like when he's fighting
those people those crazy like 300 type
of shots Charlie Hunnam is someone who's
been growing on me I I'll admit I
haven't seen Sons of Anarchy everyone
says I should watch it there's a lot of
television shows out there and I don't
have time to watch every [ __ ] show on
goddamn Netflix Sons of Anarchy I hear
he's great in it but the movies I've
seen him in I haven't been like wow
Charlie Hunnam is amazing he looks like
he could be really [ __ ] bad as in
this though story feels rather more
contained because from my you know King
Arthur experiences of watching several
renditions of the King Arthur folklore
yep Arthur and there
Lancelot you have Guinevere you have
Merlin and I don't see any I think your
advantage is Lancelot at one point but I
don't think you see Lancelot in this
movie I don't I don't remember Guinevere
being in this trailer either it seems
like this is strictly about King
Arthur's origin tale just art there not
Arthur during the round tables Arthur
and then this is the gritty version the
one where he's a rebel I don't want to
be a leader but he will be a leader by
the end of this well shows more serious
and epic it's a Guy Ritchie directed
film so I'm sure there'll be a lot of
humor and fused throughout it and Guy
Ritchie is really great at doing that
you know that's why we work so well with
Sherlock Holmes if using one of that
humour and bantering there is he
understands British bands are pretty
well and it's got a lot of British
actors in here so I'm sure there'll be a
lot of that too it looks like Merlin
would fit well into this movie though
because of all the mystical elements you
were seeing at play here if you don't
have laughs on Guinevere I'm hoping like
Merlin at least make some type of
appearance or cameo because they're
obviously trying to franchise this [ __ ]
[ __ ] little fingers in this man
Shanghai Knights Game of Thrones now
this you'll never see him in a story
that takes place in modern day and if
you do it'll look kind of weird yes we
might let my guard down I thought that
was a really sick trailer and I'm rather
sold on watching this movie you know a
lot of the times you see trailers for
films you get so many different kinds of
trailers for every movie a lot of time
it's kind of easy to tell when you're
like okay that was a cool trailer but
I'm pretty sure the movie still might
not be that great but would this show
the way it was all edited together
something tells me this will at least be
a really entertaining epic time yeah I'm
so loving you guys are gonna watch this
by the way you recommended it all right
well if you're new to the channel and
you can subscribe today get accepted you
fellow
reject and once again shut up to the man
who requested this jet yen all I know
are Asian action stars